ich gehe diesen weg hier lang wo steht
das hier meine sachen sind die mir
weggenommen wurden nach meinem troll und
dann werde ich weiter geträumt und muss
jetzt zum die jungs grundstück alter
danke danke jetzt werde ich nämlich
geträumt jetzt beginnt der troll krieg
hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
vom mega projekt das ist ganz spontan
aufgenommene 225 war gestern am 24 auf
dem video day
ich bin immer noch total kaputt ich habe
heute schon zwei videos hochgeladen
allerdings meinten das kind contest eine
person erlitt megaprojekt unter dachte
mir so [ __ ] ich wusste ich habe etwas
vergessen hat durch zu laden und
deswegen muss ich jetzt wissen
megaprojekt auf dem pay scam geht auch
nicht weil die grad noch die ganzen
fotos nicht beim video der gemacht habe
über transportiert ich habe keine fotos
wo ich bin habe ich nur zwei oder drei
stück also da brauchte gar nicht fragen
ich hab auch keine videos machen kann
weil einfach überall leute waren und ich
habe nur so ein paar fotos von so ein
paar auftritten nicht anhalt meinen
eltern zeigen wollte was alles also da
brauchte gar nicht nachfragen das habe
ich leider vergessen eventuell nehme ich
nächstes jahr hinten anderen typen mit
der dann irgendwie kameramann macht oder
irgendwie sowas keine ahnung also das
erstmal dazu sonst ich wollte eigentlich
müssen die frau wartete stehen still da
mein essen ist in 20 deswegen wird das
keine lange folge keine längere folge
wenn du jemanden trotz schlägt er zurück
viel spaß beim suchen
du willst deine kisten mit seinem staff
wieder gilt zu alter alter du elender
penner die elendige penner die elendige
penner entweder was war es komme aber
ich glaub nicht ob das wahr debitor
balkone wird schreiben tumor 000 gomez
toni kroos über stolz ein bisschen ich
zuerst mal ist ein bisschen runter oder
es war dann könnte es noch gewesen sein
es könnte ja ich glaube es war die
bieter oder halbtrocken fans aber diesen
im urlaub also ich glaube es ich denke
es war die bieter
also meine kiste zweck junge das wird so
sein dass ich zu den koordinaten
hinfliegen da steht ein anderes schild
dann steht wieder einstellten dasteht
als sie es steht in meinem haus oder
irgendwie sowas aber egal später mal mit
jetpack läuft auf jeden fall - 157 464
hat ist gar nicht so weit 4 164 464 job
ist die errichtung oder er auf höhe 25
ich werde dann völlig runter lava also
ich hoffe ihr hört nicht im hintergrund
die uhr die ich an gemacht haben also
sonne sondern links habe ich an gemacht
so eine ich das sagen sondern sondern
eine eieruhr wenn es fertig ist wenn man
was 464 524 464 er ich hoffe dass jetzt
einfach mal 464 folge des grad nachts
ist ironie aber nicht mit mir 'du ich
mach hier so mich immer auf zwei blöcken
runter graben damit mir nicht so was
passieren kann dass ich nicht immer voll
oder sowas so und zwar jetzt geht's los
wir begeben uns auf die suche nach
meinen sachen werde ich geträumt man
weiß es nicht und wenn hier nicht die
sachen sind die personen die auch immer
das gespräch schreibt mir das mal bitte
in die kommentare hier seid doch
bestimmt aktive megaprojekt kuka egal
bei wem
ob ihr das jetzt irgendwie bei gomez war
entweder komme oder die bieter ich
glaube im brockenhaus war das nicht
glaube ich kann auch sein dass noch
gewesen waren aber also schreibt mir das
einfach in die kommentare
wer das war woraufhin das halt irgendwie
raus oder fragt euch herum keine ahnung
und schreibt überall bei jedem den ich
geträumt habe also die betonbrocken fans
komme und drei wie schreibt darunter
bitte in die kommentare von crafter
macht krieg weil das wasser ich bin
gleich auf 5 25
ich hoffe dass ihr noch alles geht bei
mir scheint gerade voll die sonne rein
deswegen
ist es bei mir alles ein bisschen
diese stand eine redstone fackel und
hier gehe zu young minecraft das rp es
war mojang seine verdammte schnauze
halten alte ich habe es gesagt ich habe
es gesagt ich gehe diesen weg hier lang
wo steht das hier meine sachen sind die
mir weggenommen wurden nach meinem troll
und dann werde ich weiter geträumt und
muss jetzt zum jungs grundstück alter
danke danke jetzt werde ich nämlich
geträumt jetzt beginnt der troll krieg
ok freude
gut dann laufen
korrigiert zum gemeindehaus der soll
seine verdammte schnauze halten
der träumt mich jetzt so dass die kiste
im nachhinein irgendwo bei mir unter dem
grundstück steht das könnte ich euch so
schwören
ich könnte mein leben darauf schwören
dass die irgendwo auf meinem grundstück
steht so übrigen wollte ich noch so ein
ganz großes los den schild hierhin
machen
wann kommt chrome kann alle die beim
videodreh waren die wissen was ich meine
den planungen kraft eine kiste ist im
keller irgendwo da unten sind noch
landmark sucht sie fast alles repariert
in meinem keller
ich dachte ich muss jetzt noch weiter
herum laufen aber dass wir relativ
erbärmlich wenn es jetzt vorbei ist
in welchem keller denn jetzt stelle ich
mich auch noch radio sinn und ist so was
alles als ob die hier im keller lässt
ihn im großen keller aber den keller so
alter alter brauch ich dachte dass ich
so gerne eingebaut wo ist denn die
da ist nix
ich könnte schwören die ihn irgendwo
hier am rand
sowohl diese total im schatten das würde
keiner sieht er provokant er die dann
sonst hingestellt haben wenn du musst ja
mit der portal venture mit genommen
haben weil ich glaube nicht dass er die
ganze sache dann immer wieder von küste
zu küste weiter platziert
übrigens muss ich noch mal die ganze
welt machen das sehr gefährlich hier
diese sind hierbei fackeln
geht doch auch alles mit renten nicht
mit rechten dingen zu ihr mensch es kann
sein dass meine vielleicht irgendwann
klingelt keine ahnung
komplett wird an alter mann ich wollte
eigentlich nur ein troll plan weil ich
war verschiedene trotz gegen brocken
flammen bzw
verschiedene rache danke an die person
die mir das in die kommentare
geschrieben hat wenn du denn noch weiß
dass du das war's dann schreib einfach
schreiben stichwahl
und zwar werde ich über die wollte teile
von denen über die energiequelle ganz
weit oben was drüber bauen also auf die
höchste höhe
damit die zeit nicht merken und da das
dann trotzdem keine energie bekommen
dann werde ich ihr ganzes grundstück
voll mit diesem ms sprayer sprühen also
voll mit diesem dass das aluminium
erstes dieses material wie auch bei mir
auf grundstücke strater hier ist links
um eine kiste der meinte irgendwo unten
sind auch noch jens marx oder irgend
sowas auch noch behindert man wo ist die
ich weiß nicht ob er die folgen
hochgeladen hat leute aber ich würde
euch jetzt einfach mal um hilfe bäten
dass ihr mit also ein bisschen bei
hälfte von wegen
ja der die dauernd dahin gestellt so
irgendwie wo kann ich denn sein
hier habe ich alles abgeräumt
dh es so scheiße ich hätte nicht
anfangen sollen mit trollen weil jetzt
kriege ich immer wieder zurück und jetzt
werde ich auch immer wieder zurückholen
weil ich eine person bin die sowas nicht
auf sich sitzen lässt alter wie viele
eier die legen dann hast du rufst naja
als er das kann ich nicht sein
übrigens dank an die person meinte dass
ich hier einfach ein portal hinsetzen
kann ich mich total vergessen weil ich
dachte ich muss die ganzen hühner so
überholen zu locken fans aber ich kann
doch einfach ein portal sitzen was
willst du denn hier so ich kann auch
einfach ein portal setzt und dann gehen
die hühner dadurch alter so viel am
spawn hey ich habe doch alles
ausgeleuchtet oder natürlich nicht den
der kaputten sache es fängt an zu regnen
und girl sodann gehe ich jetzt mal im
panel das kann nicht sein
leute also ich bin da echt jetzt auf
eure hilfe angewiesen und zwar möchte
ich über 10 milliarden kommentare sehen
egal was ich mich allgemein viele
kommentare sehen weil ich kommentar auch
immer regelmäßig beantwortet aber ganz
einfach wo hat er diese verfügte kiste
hingestellt das kann auch nicht sein
dass ich die nicht finden der alter ich
schaue es nochmal alles hier durch also
ich denke nicht dass der das ganze in
sonne in seinen höhleneingang gestellt
hat oder also das glaube ich jetzt
ehrlich gesagt nicht
so verhält es sich verstehe ich jetzt
echt nicht wo kann er dann hingestellt
haben als wenn er die unter das lager
unter die lava gestellt hat dann bin ich
echt stolz auf ihn weil dann wäre es
witzig aber wenn die dann nicht ist dann
will ich es einfach nur weise nicht
komisch wo kann ich denn sonst sein
ich muss das ja allgemein mal irgendwie
alles zu bauen
der hat die 1000 prozentig irgendwo in
die lager gestellt und es ist eine
diamonds es deswegen kann ja nicht
kaputt gehen
ach scheiße naja freunde dann werde ich
mich jetzt einfach mal daran setzen dass
ich hier oben was hat drüber laufen
lasse hallo vater da so
man da und da noch ein und jetzt ja so
du kommst jetzt nämlich weg ich muss
hier oben so eine riesige fläche voll
mit wasser heiß machen und die dann ab
damit das wasser darüber fließen kann so
und was ich dafür auch brauche ist ein
wassereimer und zwar glaube ich brauche
ich sogar nur 1 für das was ich vorhabe
wenn das funktioniert die folge es auch
gleich wieder vorbei weil die folge kann
nicht so lang sein oder ich mache dann
einfach noch ein anhang dran wo ich dann
meine kiste noch suche und das schaffe
ich auch nicht wenn es draußen da muss
ich noch essen die folgen bis heute noch
online weil das ist gleich zum ersten
mal ist eine folge aufnehmen und am
selben tag die noch hoch kommt also von
dem let's play bei sonst für display
muss wenn ihm eine szene wie heraus und
so was alles so und wo habe ich junge
mann der einmal war da drin
scheiße ich gucke so rum so möchten wir
nun einmal fakt 1 23 kommen jetzt martin
reimer 23
welche waffe durch den wasser aus den
wäldern
obwohl was die bieter oder was mojang
schaut einfach bei beiden ich denke es
war mojang weil sonst würde das
schreiben geht zum ball greift das haus
oder ich weiß es nicht ich brauche das
hier in in wievielen richtung muss ich
denn hier gehen
meine rotec noch dass meine lieben zu
hat noch sand in sich gehen das ist auf
jeden fall gut weil danach werde ich
schön was zu essen holen und danach
schön das verputzen dabei schön rändern
und danach hochladen
so reicht das schon mit wasser so das
ist nämlich mein alter [ __ ] ich dachte
er macht ihr so heftige action geht es
in alle richtungen aber der geht ja nur
dahin wo links ist aber trotzdem waschen
wieso geht der andere wasserstrahl an
die runter ist da etwa eine kiste
verpackt ich hab keine ahnung jährlich
jetzt warum geht es runter so was ich
nun noch machen muss ist dass hier
einmal platzieren
da das ist hier dann auch noch über
fließt also ich muss jetzt endlich genau
darauf stehen erwartet das wäre heftig
dass jetzt genauso in der mitte ist anni
passt gut so kaum was los ist es
wirklich damit ich dachte das fließt
also drauf verbreitet sich ans todes
aber es geht nicht
doch ist das geht es geht geht perfekt
aber jetzt wird die grundbeleuchtung auf
jeden fall schon ein bisschen dunkler
sein
unter der es ist dunkler geworden aber
naja
die lava auswechslung mehr oder weniger
so du kommst mit so das muss jetzt alles
abbauen oxidieren solche carry auf
stellen abzubauen gibt die keinen bock
dran oder ich mache mir diamond drill
oder sowas aber dafür braucht der mann
einfach den also ein diamant blog klar
ich meine guckt euch den das haus an
es ist doch wohl das ist doch keine
ahnung junge meine diamant sachen sind
in der verschickten kiste und dies unter
meinem grundstück fakt egal ich versuche
jetzt einfach mal dass mit tommy um
abzubauen ich glaub ja das geht oder
ich ersetze dem das einfach durch ein
labsal blog jagd geht
ich gucke ich mir lange tier nur aus
level kommt ja wieder als schutzschild
euer leben entsteht meinen penis auf
meinem grundstück da brauch ich noch
wolle für sie ist übrigens auch sehr
viele dass ich mir strings von simon
holen soll
und ich dann hat andy das darf ja nicht
mehr jemand alle dass ich mir von simon
strings nehmen kann wie man meinte ok
ich hab sie mal nicht gefragt aber ich
glaube das ähnlich und strings und dem
jetzt auch nicht so wichtig oder ich
meinte frings ist ja kein
ausschlaggebender bestandteil des spiels
und das ist kein hühnchen entstanden
chance
ich mache ihnen jetzt ein nazi block
management 150 789 so hier rein
übrigens leute was immer man die
kommentare schreiben könnt was ich
geplant hatte war eine serie die ich in
die parade schnell oder in die sowas wo
ich einfach riecht also es gibt ja den
spielmodus rage mode und ich spiele
einfach irgendwas ob es dabei wie
gamestop kretschmann ich finde man sie
keinen unterschied
jedenfalls wartet davon weiß ich etwas
speed shop machen das dach
betreten verboten ist auch noch wichtig
dass es da draufsteht wunderschön und
zwar werde ich da einfach richtig
ausrasten wenn ich spiele ich werde
immer rumschreien das was als ich weiß
nicht ob so was schon gibt ich kenne die
us-kunden von broken fans und teilen des
simon wo die halter sie reden aber das
wird dann halt so eine runde wo ich halt
immer übels ausrasten sowas als ich weiß
nicht ob so was schon gibt wenn zum
beispiel geht das natürlich nicht machen
wenn doch also wenn du das noch nicht
geht wenn es das schon gibt an welche
das was natürlich nicht mehr kennt ihn
aber auch plänen kommt darauf an was ich
vielleicht sonst noch machen könnte
ihnen ja sowas weil ich hätte mal bock
auf sowas einfach umschreiben oder auch
so was wie nah sie runde oder in gesorgt
könnt ihr mir auch in die kommentare
einfach schreiben dafür sind die
kommentare natürlich da und ich schon
meine uhr ist abgelaufen
geil ich weiß nicht ob es klingeln habt
habt hört klingeln lassen oder so aber
ich bin jetzt erstmal die aufnahmen
heute abend noch mal mit re wie auch
heute ist der 25 die aufnahme kommt
direkt jetzt online
also schreiben konnten die kommentare
vielleicht hat euch als kind contest
auch gut gefallen
bisher war die resonanz relativ gut ich
wurde auch schon in skype von relativ
vielen leuten angeschrieben die auch
ihre skins 3 zeigen wollten
es geht dann heute abend mit dem ich ja
weiter auf die folge kommt dann morgen
da werden wir das bordell weiterbauen
was da hinten gerade im gange ist und
wir werden außerdem dann meine kiste
suchen beziehungsweise ich wenn mein
keller aufräumen ich werd strings holen
ich werde holen und dann werde ich bei
broken verstreuen und ja dann freunde
sehen wir uns dann beim nächsten mal
wieder mit euch gefallen ob ich mich
über eine bewertung freuen wir das zeigt
mir dass euch sowas gefällt wo ich so
tolle aber auch geträumt werde wo ich
andererseits noch produktiv bin und dann
wieder in bist du alles also simon hat
sein haus repariert das hab ich in
seiner aufnahmen schon gesehen und wir
sehen uns damit demnächst mal wieder
typisch